[Music]
imagine walking down a sidewalk and
coming across this creature it's a
gerbil and a robot suit and it's a 3d
sketch created by david zinn he's a
popular street artist known for drawings
like these all made from chalk and
charcoal his mission to show you that
you do not need fancy art supplies to
make art
his work has appeared worldwide from a
village square in germany to the streets
of laguna beach california and our jamie
yukis looks at how zinn brings his
sketches to life
what do you look for what's a canvas on
the street oh anything to most people
this might look like an ordinary street
but to david zinn it offers endless
possibilities there's strange little
posts in the ground sometimes no one can
tell me why they're there so they might
be there for this person you know
just for you to start drawing maybe who
knows for more than 20 years the
michigan native worked as a freelance
commercial artist until a box of
colorful sidewalk chalk convinced him to
leave his day job that is a squirrel's
tail
the 52 year old now creates whimsical 3d
drawings right on the spot using
everything from manhole covers to weeds
and street cracks as his inspiration a
few minutes ago this was just a patch
and it wanted to be a hole in the ground
yeah i saw that hole in the ground yeah
so it's working that's it
why did you decide to start doing art
with chalk of all things
the honest answer is that i was looking
for an excuse to be outside on a nice
day that was how it started that's it um
yeah we all seem to have chalk in our
house it's just very easy to come by
which is one of the things that i think
makes it a good thing to make art with
because it's not precious philomena the
flying pig is just one of the characters
that often pops up there was
and is
one perfectly flat small brick right
here that is perfect for a pig head so
that's where the pig had to go and this
is where the window ledge had to go
because it couldn't go anywhere else
what kind of chalk do you use anything i
can get my hands on it doesn't take long
for zinn to attract a crowd from long
time fans look at me i always get tears
in my eyes when i see it i just love it
it just makes me so happy to first time
onlookers he was like checking out the
concrete over there they conquered over
here it's like what's going on i never
seen anyone doing this before the ground
was perfectly dry if zin isn't striking
up conversations with real people is
that what you want to be
he can often be seen talking to the
characters he's bringing to life where
are your arms i loved how he kind of
explained his personal thought and his
personal connection to it which made me
really feel like this really comes from
his heart this stuff isn't pre-planned
it's definitely from the heart and i
think he might be done
still even the most heartfelt piece of
art can get washed away with just a few
raindrops but zinn says that's all well
part of the draw famous works of art
hanging in museums gets seen by
thousands of people every day but this
you could be in among the dozens of
people who get to see this while it
exists that's pretty special is there a
lesson in all this for people
i hope so i think that's part of what
this is meant to do to celebrate the
fact that we walk through spaces on our
way to somewhere else all the time and
don't really take the time to notice
where we are and it's helped me a lot to
actually appreciate every single place
that i am for what it can do
yeah
that'll do
at least until it rains
for cbs morning's jamie yukis laguna
beach california
i love that kind of creativity see we
see a crack in the sidewalk it's a crack
he sees it as a piece of art that you
can build on i know but so it's so
transient like here it is until it rains
i wonder how he makes a living you know
i know he has support because his art is
beautiful yeah but i wonder
i don't know